do you know what maybe they tank this
year they got rg3 they don't take a
quarterback and is that paraphrasing it
correctly my dad's pretty close all
right let me bring in Ross Tucker let
give me is that your Browns theory here
Ross I don't think it's a conspiracy
theory tan it's just taking a look at
what they've done so far I mean they
were three and 13 they let four of their
six best players leave via free agency
they let their two leading tackler they
just cut Karlos Dansby and Donte Whitner
their cheer leading tacklers they don't
need to tank then they are very clearly
the worst team in the NFL I mean
Tennessee in San Francisco might be in
the running but the Browns are going to
be historically bad next year and with
everything they're doing all these
Harvard guys are taking a really long
term view of this thing I think they
have to consider the very real
possibility they're going to have to
number one pick here's draft deshaun
Watson is a terrific prospect it's
horrific quarterback and so one option
they might have and they may already be
ahead of us here is sign rg3 per year if
rg3 somehow please great to have under
contract for next year if he gets
destroyed like I expect you probably
will as the team well why not take a
really good player number to a really
good player at the top of round number
to get some good players and thence
draft Shawn Watson number one overall
next year because there's a very strong
likelihood in my mind they'll have the
number one thing but if I said you could
take deshaun Watson or carson wentz who
you taking i'd probably take carson
wentz and that's just based on you know
calling the FCS championship game the
last couple years I am a really really
big believer in him but I don't know how
to the Browns feel about that that's how
I feel about it but the show Watson
looks pretty darn good too I just know
this much day
and if they're really as smart as
they're pretending to be or as hard as
they think they are then don't you have
to do some research into what
quarterbacks would be available next
year before you pull the trigger on when
sore golf or whoever yeah I have to know
if Carson Wentz is a franchise
quarterback and you know it there's a
lot of guesswork in that as well but if
he's too good to pass up then I take him
if I feel like he and deshaun Watson are
similar or about the same you know as
far as you know how great they're going
to be then I would trade that number two
pick i'd trade down get out of it get
more pics and then try to build
something here for the future but you
know it's the cleveland browns they find
the banana peel just about every year
i'm still trying to figure out why they
even signed rd three in the first place
i mean if you take carson wentz with the
number two overall thick why did you
sign rg3 to play until whence is ready
well I mean Josh McElveen can play
better for the Browns until when she's
ready did you sign rg3 to be a mentor
Josh McCown is like that's what he is
he's a great mentor for young
quarterback so I think them signing
Archie three gave as much credence to my
theory as anything that and the fact
that they are by far the worst team in
the NFL for the 2016 Steve will they win
a game next season uh yes I think you
Jackson has enough up his sleeve for
them to win a game but yeah I don't know
what the over/under is in Vegas but as
soon as we hang up I might have it all
under as soon as possible the other way
that is that they never have an
over/under of less than like five you
know what I mean there's no chance the
browns win five games next year no
chance everybody listening should call
and take the under right now we do we
know what the over/under for wins is
with the Cleveland Browns in Vegas guys
yeah we're good we're gonna have to
check on that all right hey thanks for
joining us thanks for giving mclovin
some ammo there because I think until I
arted to be critical of it to a certain
degree he was going to take credit for
it so then he started to blame you after
that thanks for joining us ross it
happened nope all right Ross Tucker the
Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience